programming throwdown episode 64 cryptography take it away jason i actually want to talk about interns and uh how important that is, understanding how the whole internship process works and the implications there. I'll kind of walk through sort of the whole internship kind of cycle. Basically, typically you interview, so you're typically in college. You could be undergrad, you're, so you're typically in college, you could be undergrad, graduate student, doctoral student. Um, you will interview around like December, January ish, you know, so you'll apply around,
Programming Throwdown 第64期，密码学。Jason，你来开始吧。其实我想谈谈实习生，以及这有多重要，了解整个实习流程是如何运作的及其意义。我会梳理一下整个实习周期。基本上，通常你会进行面试，那时你通常还在上大学。你可能是本科生、研究生或博士生。嗯，你会在12月、1月左右面试，所以你大约在……
I guess, November, December. Um, but definitely check with whatever company you're interested in cause it varies. Um, and then, you know, you'll do a typically a couple of phone interviews and then if you're interested in because it varies. And then, you know, you'll do typically a couple of phone interviews. And then if you're accepted, you'll sort of formally accept the offer and then you'll be committed to spending your summer at, you know, whatever company you apply to. It's pretty cool. I mean, I think it's very sort of loose. Like I've seen really amazing, super exciting internships where you're basically a full-time engineer. You have a ton of responsibility.
我想是11月、12月申请。嗯，但一定要向你感兴趣的公司确认，因为情况各不相同。嗯，然后，你知道，你通常会进行几次电话面试，如果……因为情况各不相同。然后，你知道，你通常会进行几次电话面试。如果被录取，你会正式接受录用通知，然后你就会承诺在暑假期间去你申请的公司工作。这很酷。我的意思是，我觉得这很灵活。我见过非常棒、超级令人兴奋的实习，在那里你基本上就是一名全职工程师。你承担了大量的责任。
You have a lot of help and some amazing work comes out of it. I've seen internships that didn't go as well. So because it's such a short time, it's there's going to be high variance. Right. But one really key thing is it's super, super important to do an internship if you want to go into industry. It raises your chances of getting a job significantly. I mean, there are times in companies I've worked at where there have been hiring freezes and they still will um hire people who are interns um even through the hiring freeze so it's really important i personally haven't done an internship but uh i have uh over the years kind of mentored interns and uh that's another part of it is you'll get you'll get paired up with a mentor who is kind of responsible, kind of like a manager.
你得到了很多帮助，并由此产生了一些了不起的工作成果。我也见过不太顺利的实习。因为时间太短，所以会有很大的差异。对吧。但一个非常关键的事情是，如果你想进入行业，实习是超级、超级重要的。它会显著提高你获得工作的机会。我的意思是，在我工作过的公司里，有时会出现招聘冻结，但他们仍然会雇佣实习生，即使在招聘冻结期间也是如此，所以这真的很重要。我个人没有做过实习，但我多年来指导过实习生，这是其中的另一部分，你会和一个导师配对，他有点像经理，负责你的工作。
And they're responsible for helping you, making sure that, you know, if you're blocked on something that they can get you unblocked. Of course, this is really important for an internship where you only have a couple of months. And I think, Patrick, you actually did an internship, right? I did. I interned at a company that I ended up going to work for once I graduated, because that's like a thing companies try to do is for the interns that do, you know, well, they sort of already learned about them. They've started spent some money training them. And so they try to be generous and giving them offers to come work there the other thing i don't think you mentioned is that being in engineering specifically computer science i've never heard of an internship that was not paid oh that's a good point so in other
他们负责帮助你，确保如果你在某件事上遇到阻碍，他们能帮你解决。当然，这对只有几个月的实习来说非常重要。我想，Patrick，你确实做过实习，对吧？是的。我在一家公司实习，毕业后我就去那里工作了，因为这是公司试图做的事情，对于表现好的实习生，他们已经了解了他们。他们已经花了一些钱来培训他们。所以他们会尽量大方地提供录用通知，让他们来工作。另外，我觉得你没提到的一点是，在工程领域，特别是计算机科学，我从来没听说过不带薪的实习。哦，那是个好观点。所以在其他
sort of disciplines it's very common to have internships that are not paid, that you sort of are expected to give work away in exchange for the experience. But all of the programming internships I know of are paid, and they're actually paid pretty well, like much better than the sort of other summer jobs I took that were internships. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, internships are paid if you do some type of engineering role um i have a friend who's in biology and uh their internships are not paid so it's kind of uh um and and they still it's still very common to do internships even in that field so so we're super lucky to uh be in a field where they pay uh interns um and uh, I think it's a great experience. The other part of it is,
学科中，不带薪的实习很常见，你被期望用工作来换取经验。但我知道的所有编程实习都是带薪的，而且薪水相当不错，比我做过的其他暑期实习工作要好得多。是的，绝对是。是的，如果你从事某种工程角色，实习是有薪水的。我有一个朋友在生物学领域，他们的实习是不带薪的，所以这有点……而且即使在那个领域，做实习仍然非常普遍。所以我们非常幸运能在一个为实习生提供薪水的领域工作，而且我认为这是一种很棒的经历。另一部分是，
you know, there's definitely a big rift, I think, between academia and industry right now. I mean, if you're in academia, you probably are being taught about linked lists and about hash tables and things like that, which are super important. And then typically you'll have maybe one software engineering class, but that class will, at least at my university, was just woefully out of date. You know, it's like UML diagrams or something, which is like, you know, popular in the nineties or something. And so, you know, getting an internship gives you just like an extraordinary experience. It's very hard to sort of replicate in school.
你知道，我认为现在学术界和工业界之间确实存在巨大的鸿沟。我的意思是，如果你在学术界，你可能正在学习链表、哈希表之类的东西，这些非常重要。然后通常你可能只有一门软件工程课，但那门课，至少在我所在的大学，简直是过时得离谱。你知道，就像UML图之类的，那是九十年代流行的东西。所以，你知道，获得实习机会能给你带来非凡的体验。这在学校里很难复制。
Um, it also will help your interview skills. Um, you know, it'll look, it'll look good on your resume and all of that. So, uh, definitely check it out if it's not on your radar. Um, you know, uh, it would be good to just, you know, check out some, pick your favorite companies, um, and see sort of what they have to offer on the internship side. The other part of it is it's not, uh, as big a risk for a company. So, you know, depending on state to state, but, but in general, if, if a company hires you, uh, especially if you're there for more than three months,
嗯，它也有助于提高你的面试技巧。嗯，你知道，这在你的简历上会很好看，诸如此类。所以，如果这不在你的考虑范围内，一定要去看看。嗯，你知道，去看看，挑选你最喜欢的公司，看看他们在实习方面能提供什么，这会很好。另一部分是，这对公司来说风险没那么大。所以，你知道，取决于不同的州，但总的来说，如果一家公司雇佣你，特别是如果你在那里工作超过三个月，
you know, there's definitely it's hard to get rid of people to say like perfectly honestly, it's hard, very hard to fire people in general. And I think in Europe, it's even harder. Right. And so what that means is people are going to be risk adverse. Right. They're going to take every possible precaution, um, not to be put into an awkward position. Right. And if you've done an internship
你知道，确实很难解雇人。老实说，总的来说，解雇人非常非常困难。而且我认为在欧洲，这甚至更难。对吧。所以这意味着人们会规避风险。对吧。他们会采取一切可能的预防措施，以免陷入尴尬的境地。对吧。如果你做过实习，
that, uh, that gives extraordinary signal to that company. I mean, and so if the, if it's a choice is between you and somebody else who, as far as the interview goes is, you know, maybe even a little better, did a little better in the the interview but you're a sort of a sure thing and they're just high variance because they didn't do an internship um i think that that will you know factor in right on the flip side um i don't think internships like matter to other companies um to the degree that they're worth getting so in other words like don't do an internship at a company that you would never work for just to do an internship i feel like that's a waste i think you would be better off like taking a coursera course or something and putting that on your resume i disagree um really well i'd like to hear your opinion uh so i i think you're
那会给那家公司提供非凡的信号。我的意思是，如果选择是在你和另一个人之间，就面试而言，那个人可能甚至稍微好一点，在面试中表现得稍微好一点，但你是一个确定的人选，而他们因为没有做过实习，所以存在很大的不确定性。我认为这会……你知道，起到作用。另一方面，我不认为实习对其他公司有多重要，以至于值得去争取。换句话说，不要为了实习而在一份你永远不会去工作的公司实习。我觉得那是浪费。我觉得你还不如去上Coursera课程，并把它写在简历上。我不同意。真的吗？我很想听听你的意见。所以我认为你……
it is absolutely true that doing an internship doesn't matter nearly as much to another company but even if they discount your work like work experience there or sort of you know kind of pretend that it isn't there i don't think it's a negative, right? It's not, they're not going to be like, oh, you did an internship at another company. We don't want you here. And I think there's a bunch of positives to it. One, from your end, you're going to be able to have gotten a little more experience in the process of doing that, that you can talk about during your interview, that you will help you in your last. So typically, well, sometimes internships happen at the end of your schooling, but often they happen sort of before
绝对正确的是，做实习对另一家公司来说并不那么重要。但即使他们不看重你在那里的工作经验，或者假装它不存在，我不认为这是负面的，对吧？他们不会说，哦，你在另一家公司做过实习，我们不想要你。而且我认为这有很多积极的一面。第一，从你这边来看，你在这个过程中获得了更多的经验，你可以在面试中谈论这些，这将帮助你……所以通常，嗯，有时实习发生在学业结束时，但通常它们发生在你的最后一年或最后两年之前。
your final year or before your final two years. And then it sort of gives you an opportunity to shape that last year or two years to what you learned about during your internship or what you sort of learned about the real world. I guess that sounds bad to say, but non-academia, it's sort of what Jason was alluding to. And I think all of those things actually help you when you go to interview, people can tell, oh, this person is sort of ready. Like they sort of, they've sat here, they're not going to ask, you're not going to have to ask questions like, what is it like to be a programmer? Like, what do you do all day? Those might be questions that come from someone who's not. And I think all of that sort of comes through
然后它给了你一个机会，根据你在实习中学到的东西，或者你从现实世界中学到的东西，来塑造最后一年或两年。我想说这个听起来很糟糕，但非学术界，这正是Jason所暗示的。我认为所有这些事情实际上在你去面试时都会帮助你，人们能看出来，哦，这个人已经准备好了。就像他们已经坐在那里了，你不需要问诸如“程序员是什么样的？”或者“你整天做什么？”之类的问题。这些问题可能来自没有经验的人。我认为所有这些都会体现出来。
in sort of the disposition of a person, even during interviewing, if they've done an internship before. I mean, taking a Coursera course is great. I don't know how to really compare and contrast those, but I think there is value. I mean, at some point taking it in sort of a field of computer science you're not interested
在人的气质中，即使在面试过程中，如果他们之前做过实习的话。我的意思是，参加Coursera课程很棒。我不知道该如何真正比较和对比这些，但我认为是有价值的。我的意思是，在某种程度上，在你不感兴趣的计算机科学领域，
in going into and at a company that's not very reputable or whatever at least you still get paid so there's that and like making money is sort of good to like help you get through college because I was sort of broke in college yeah same here so that was really nice and I see what you're saying
或者在一家名声不太好的公司，无论如何，至少你还是拿到了薪水，所以这一点很好。而且赚钱对帮助你度过大学生活很有帮助，因为我在大学时有点穷。是的，我也是，所以那真的很不错。我明白你的意思，
but I wouldn't say it's a case by case basis. You sort of have to make a decision. But I do actually think there's enormous value. In my time when I was back at college after doing an internship, it gave me, I feel, a much different view on my professors and what they were saying. Where it allowed me to sort of apply what was being said a little more intelligently. And sort of focus on the parts that I really wanted to make sure I knew. And sort of, in my mind, since I wasn't going in academia,
但我不会说这是个案。你必须做出决定。但我确实认为有巨大的价值。在我做完实习回到大学的那段时间里，我觉得我对教授和他们所说的话有了完全不同的看法。它让我能更聪明地应用所学的内容。并专注于我真正想确保自己掌握的部分。而且，在我看来，既然我不打算进入学术界，
it allowed me to discount some of the stuff that I realized was sort of no longer applicable to kind of the stuff I would need when I first came out of the gate. It makes sense. I mean, I think it, yeah, I mean, I'm definitely kind of like a bookworm. So, you know, it's a bit of like, I think it, yeah. I mean, I'm definitely kind of like a bookworm. So, so, you know, it's a bit of like, I think my values coming out, but yeah, I think, so maybe, I mean, one thing that I think we both agree on is definitely, you know, take the time to like intern to take the time to pick a company for your internship that you'd want to work for like that like like interning you know uh gives
它让我能够忽略一些我意识到不再适用于我刚毕业时所需的东西。这说得通。我的意思是，我想……是的，我的意思是，我绝对有点像书呆子。所以，你知道，这有点像……我想，我的价值观体现出来了，但是的，我想，也许，我的意思是，我们都同意的一点是，一定要花时间去实习，花时间为你想要工作的公司选择实习机会，就像那样……实习，你知道，会给你在实习的那家公司带来巨大的优势，所以不要浪费它。如果你真的想在通用电气（General Electric）之类的地方工作，那就去那里实习。这意味着要尽早对公司和你想要工作的地方进行研究。但是的，我明白你的观点，无论如何你都会获得大量的经验。在GE实习，然后你去别处面试，他们对GE不太了解或不在乎，你仍然会拥有原本不会有的经验。好了，新闻时间到了。所以，嗯，是的，这是其中一件事情，甚至提出来都让人害怕，但我们必须谈谈。他们在监听。嗯，是的，没错。所以，我相信每个人现在都已经看到了整个Vault 7维基解密的事情。基本上，嗯，我想，我的意思是，我
you a huge leg up at that company that you interned at and so don't kind of like waste that like if if you really want to work at you know uh general electric or something then do an internship there and and what that means is kind of really doing research kind of early on the companies and where you want to work. But yeah, I see your point that there's definitely, you get a ton of experience either way. do internship at GE and then you go interview somewhere else and they don't really know much about GE or care or something like that you're still going to have experience that's going to show that you would have had otherwise all right time for uh news so um yeah so this is this is one of these things it's almost like scary to even bring up but we have to talk about it they're listening um yeah that's right uh so so i'm sure everyone's seen by now this whole vault seven wiki leaks thing uh basically um and i guess i mean i don't
不知道这是否……我的意思是，我不知道有多少已经被证实了，我必须承认我没有太密切地关注它。但基本上，维基解密发布了一堆来自中央情报局（CIA）的文件，除其他事项外，如果你有三星智能电视，他们有一种黑客手段，可以通过你的WiFi路由器进入你的WiFi路由器。然后从那里他们可以进入你的电视，他们实际上可以随意打开麦克风。所以，嗯，据推测他们只是打开麦克风，收集所有这些音频，然后将其发送到德国，因为我想他们的想法是，如果他们被抓住了，那么他们可以说这是德国人干的。所以这是一种掩盖踪迹的方法。但是，我想显然有……而且再次强调，这都是来自维基解密。我不知道其中是否有任何真实性。我不会……我不知道。对吧。但是，根据这份报告，有
know if it's i mean i don't know how much of it has been sort of proven or not i haven't been following it too closely i have to admit but basically wiki leaks released a bunch of documents from the cia and uh among other things it, uh, if you had a Samsung smart TV, um, that they had some sort of hack where from your wifi router, um, they could like get into your wifi router. And then from there they could get into your TV and they could actually turn on the microphone, um, just at will. So, um, and so presumably they were just turning on the microphone, they're collecting all of this audio and then they were shipping it to Germany because I guess the idea was that if they get caught, then they can like say that it was the Germans who were doing it. So it was sort of like a way to cover their tracks. Um, but I guess apparently there's like, and again, this is all from the WikiLeaks. I don't know if any of it is true. I'm not gonna, I have no idea. Right. But, but, uh, according to this report, there's a
一堆美国人住在欧洲，对所有这些非法收集的数据进行分析。而且，嗯，你知道，据推测他们是在寻找那些说话方式特定或说危险话语的人，我不知道。但整件事太疯狂了。我的意思是，它远远超出了三星电视。就像iPhone，他们有iPhone的零日漏洞，他们没有告诉任何人，这样他们就可以在iPhone上监视人们。嗯，你知道，我对这个话题的无知显露出来了。我看到了最初的新闻文章，这就是我在这里链接的内容。但是，嗯，有大量的信息。嗯，如果……哦，如果你在工作，不要在工作时下载这个，就像……
bunch of Americans, you know, living in Europe doing like all this analysis on all of this illegally collected data. Um, and, uh, you know, presumably they're like looking for people who are like speaking a certain way or saying dangerous things i don't know but uh but the whole thing is crazy i mean it goes way beyond samsung tvs it's like iphones there's like zero day exploits for iphones that that that they had that they weren't giving to anyone so that they could like survey people on their iPhone. Um, uh, you know, my, my ignorance of the topic is kind of showing through. I saw the initial news article and that's kind of what I've linked here. Um, but, uh, there's a ton of information. Um, it's, uh, if, if oh if you're at work don't download this at work like like
维基解密有包含所有这些数据的压缩包，你可能不想在工作电脑上放这个。嗯，这是其中一件事情，你不会真正去想，因为它不是非法的，不像色情制品之类的。但我只是……我不知道，也许只是我太偏执了，但我觉得这可能不是你想在工作电脑上放的东西。嗯，但是的，我的意思是，你知道，当你有时间的时候，至少读读这些文章。这很迷人。我的意思是，即使这不是真的，整个故事看起来也完全合理。而且，是的，我的意思是，这是一篇很棒的读物。还有一些工具，你实际上可以下载这些Windows和Linux工具，据称可以让你……我不知道，嗅探端口之类的，我对它了解不多。
wikileaks has the zip with like all this data you probably don't want this on your work computer um um that's one of these things it's like you don't really think about because it's not really illegal it's not like pornography or something like that but i just i just i don't know maybe it's just me being paranoid but i feel like this is probably not something that you want on your work computer um um but yeah i mean you know when you have time at least read the articles uh it's it's fascinating i mean even if it's not true just the the like the whole story just seems completely plausible and uh yeah i mean it's it's it's an amazing read there's also tools you can actually download these like windows and linux tools that supposedly let you i don't know sniff ports or something i don't know too much about it
但他们有源代码和一切，这有点疯狂。是的，正如你所说，即使它是伪造的，是CIA或者CIA在背后操纵，或者不是伪造的，而是被误传、误解，谁知道呢。即使那部分不正确，那么它也会让人们思考所有这些物联网、智能电视、智能烤面包机、智能微波炉。你知道，任何时候他们放一个麦克风在上面监听你，无论出于什么原因，你知道，即使是一个合法的理由，那么有人就能想出办法接入并收集这些数据。即使公司是共谋或非共谋的。
but they have the source code and everything which is kind of wild yeah as you said even if it is sort of fabricated that it was the cia or the cia was behind that or not fabricated but whatever miscommunicated misunderstood who knows even if that part isn't correct then um it it gets people thinking about all these sort of internet of things the smart tvs the smart toasters, the smart microwave, you know, anytime they put a microphone on there to listen to you for some reason, you know, even a sort of legitimate reason, then someone could figure out a way to tap into that and gather that data. Even if the company is complicit or non-complicit with that
是的，我的意思是，我有朋友、同事，他们会用胶带封住笔记本电脑的摄像头和麦克风。我有点……我的意思是，我不认为他们是那种戴锡纸帽的人。我的意思是，我觉得，你知道，这说得通。也许你出了意外，在不该打开的时候打开了它。或者，你知道，也许你真的下载了一个病毒，安装了一些恶意软件之类的程序。对吧。但我认为“政府在操作系统中有某种零日漏洞，他们可以直接打开你的摄像头”这种想法有点夸张，有点遥不可及。但是的，在这次报告之后，我相信
yeah i mean i you know i had friends uh your co-workers who uh you know would put tape over their laptop camera and uh tape over their microphone and i kind of like i mean i didn't think they were kind of like tinfoil hat wearers or something like that. I mean, I feel like, you know, makes sense. Maybe you have an accident and you turn it on when you're not supposed to. Or like, you know, maybe you actually download a virus like you install some program that's malware or something. Right. But I thought the idea of like, oh, the government has some zero day exploit in the OS and they could just, you know, turn on your camera. Well, I thought that was kind of like a stretch like kind of out there um but yeah after this report uh i believe
它。我的意思是，我仍然没有封住我的摄像头，也许我只是不在乎是否有人在看着我。但是的，我完全认为我可能随时被监视，这有点奇怪。我不……听起来……哦，你说吧。对不起。这听起来很傻，但你说把胶带贴在摄像头上，我实际上做过几次，因为我们过去有一个视频会议工具，可以选择打开或关闭视频，
it i mean i still haven't taped over my camera maybe i just don't care if someone's watching me um but but yeah i totally think that i could be watched at any time which is which is which is kind of strange i don't sounds... Oh, go ahead. I'm sorry. This sounds really silly, but you said put tape over the camera, and I have actually done that a couple times because we used to have a video conferencing tool that had the option of having video on or off,
有时你可能没注意或者配置不对，它会默认打开视频。然后直到你意识到并关掉它，人们才会看到你……你知道，不是在做奇怪的事情，只是让你措手不及。所以我确实在上面贴了东西。当我不认为有人在看的时候，我会抓抓脸，你知道，你只是做这些仪式性的事情。是的，我的意思是，这有点尴尬，对吧？所以我用电工胶带把它封住了，就像那种你看不透的不透明胶带。
and sometimes you would sort of not be paying attention or not have the configuration right, and it would turn on the video by default. And then until you sort of realized it and turned it off people would see you sort of you know no not doing something weird it just sort of catch you off guard and so i actually did have something over it when i don't think people are watching i like scratch my face like you know you just do these like yeah ritual things and yeah i mean it's kind of embarrassing right and so i put electrical tape over it like some opaque tape that you couldn't see through.
因为我觉得这说得通。然后前几天有人用了玻璃纸胶带，就像透明的透明胶带。你知道，在他们的摄像头上有点模糊。我起初没明白。然后我意识到并请他们确认这就是原因。这有点……第一，它没那么粘，因为当你看着它时没那么明显。此外，一些电脑使用摄像头进行环境光感应，或者在该区域进行环境光感应。
Because I thought that made sense. And then someone the other day had cellophane tape, like clear scotch tape. You know, it's like sort of hazy over theirs. And I didn't get it at first. And then I, like, realized and then asked them to confirm that this was why. It's sort of, one, it wasn't as tacky because it wasn't as obvious when you looked at it. Also, some of the computers used the camera to do ambient light sensing or in that area to do ambient light sensing.
如果你用胶带封住它，你就毁了那个功能。或者，抱歉，电工胶带或一张纸。但如果你贴上玻璃纸胶带，它仍然可以感应到光线，但一切仍然太模糊。对，对。这说得通。我当时想，哦，我想这看起来很傻。但对我来说，我只是觉得，哇，这真的很聪明。是的，完全正确。所以如果你不想做得太绝，我们现在会看到很多这种情况，我想。嗯，你知道，我们会看到整个智能手机外壳市场，可以覆盖和揭开摄像头。
And if you tape over it with tape, you ruin that. Or, like, sorry, electrical tape or a piece of paper. But if you put the cellophane tape, it can still sense the light, but everything is still too blurry. Right, right. That makes sense. I was like, oh, I guess that seems silly. But to silly but to me i was just like wow that's really smart yeah totally so if you don't want to go all the way we're going to yep we're going to see a lot of this now i think um you know like we're going to see a whole market of of smartphone cases that can you know cover and uncover the camera.
我只是觉得这会发生。我的感觉恰恰相反。我觉得人们被可怕地脱敏了，根本不在乎这个。好吧，我的意思是，如果是我的话，你是对的。我真的不在乎。也许那是一件可怕的事情。但不，我认为即使只有1%的人足够在乎，那也足以构成一个市场，让某人制造一个带盖子的外壳之类的。我不是否认会制造这种外壳。我只是否认它们会被使用。
I just feel like this is a thing that's going to happen. I feel the opposite. I feel like people are scarily desensitized and not caring about this. Well, I mean, you'd be right in the case of me. I don't really care enough. Maybe that's a scary thing. But no, I think that even if 1% of the people care enough, that's enough of a market for someone to make a case with a lid or something. I'm not denying cases will be made. I'm just denying that they're going to get used.
是的，我同意这一点。好吧，我的新闻文章是关于SHA-1碰撞的。所以我想这是来自谷歌宣布的……我猜他们试图给它起个酷名字，他们叫它“Shattered”（破碎）。所以他们给这个漏洞命名了，它不是真正的漏洞，但有一种命名漏洞的传统。所以他们叫它“Shattered”。但它实际上是SHA-1，这是一种哈希数据的方法，这意味着你获取一个文档或一段数据，然后逐字节或逐组字节地通过算法运行它，你会得到一些东西，它被称为哈希值。它是该数据的一种表示，这样如果你对数据做任何更改，在统计学上是不可能的
Yeah, I agree with that. Well, my news article is about Shaw 1 collision. So I guess this is from Google announced i i guess they were trying to call it something cool they called it shattered so they named the bug it's not really a bug but there's a tradition of naming i guess exploits and bugs so they named it shattered but what it really is is sha one which is a way of hashing the data which means you sort of take a document or a bit of data and you run it byte by byte or sets of bytes by sets of bytes through an algorithm and you get some, it's called a hashback. It's some representation of that data so that if you make any change to the data, it is statistically improbable
哈希值对于两个不同的输入是相同的。现在，当然，如果你的哈希值比你的输入小，这总是可能的，对吧？所以如果你有一个256字节的输入，而你只使用一个字节的哈希，那么当然总是有机会它们会发生碰撞。但如果哈希值足够大，碰撞的几率会急剧下降。对吧，你可以想象，对于256，一个字节的数字，256种组合，任何两个文档会有什么……1/256的碰撞几率。然后还有所谓的“生日问题”，对吧，如果你不习惯处理它，会有一点反直觉，你的碰撞几率上升得比你想象的要快。但即使如此，对于更长的哈希值，长期以来，期望出现碰撞（即两个不同的输入导致相同的结果）是不合理的。而这之所以糟糕，是因为如果你想象有人……当你下载时看到哈希码，特别是像安全工具，像一个
that the hash is the same for two different inputs. Now, of course, if your hash is smaller than your input, it's always possible, right? So if you have an input that's 256 bytes and you use only one byte hash, then of course there's always you know there's always a chance that they'll have a collide a collision um but with a big enough hash the chance of collision goes down dramatically right you could imagine you know for 256 um a one byte number a 256
SSH工具，你会看到，哦，这是哈希值，你应该在你的电脑上对它进行哈希处理，以确保你下载的东西与作者预期的相符。这样你就知道没有人更改过它。而有了碰撞，他们可以给你一个病毒而不是SSH工具。所以谷歌在这里所做的是创建了两个不同的PDF。我实际上没有打开这些PDF，但我读到它们本质上是两张图片。所以在第一个PDF上，有一张图片。在第二个PDF上，
combinations that any two documents have what would that be one in 256 chance of collision um and then there's sort of the what do they call it the the birthday problem where right the there's sort of a little bit of unintuitiveness if you're not used to dealing with it where your chance of collision goes up more quickly than you would otherwise sort of think um but even with that that with the longer hashes it sort of was for a long time unreasonable to expect that there would be a collision which is two different inputs causing the same result and the reason why that's bad is if you imagine someone is like when you see the sort of hash codes for downloads when you download especially like security tools like an
有一张完全不同的图片。它们看起来一点也不像。但如果你通过这个SHA-1算法运行它们来生成哈希，哈希将是相同的。这意味着……对，而且他们是故意这样做的。对，他们找到了两个碰撞的不同文档。
ssh tool and you'll see like oh here's the hash and you're supposed to hash it on your computer to make sure that the thing you download matches the thing the author intended to and so that way you know nobody's changed it and with a collision they could give you a virus instead of an ssh tool and so what google did here was created two different PDFs. And I haven't actually opened the PDFs, but I read that they were essentially two images. So on the first PDF, there's an image. On the second PDF,
对，而且是的，他们可以……而且重要的一点是，因为你可以生成随机数据并对其进行哈希处理，然后生成更多随机数据并对其进行哈希处理，最终你会得到一个碰撞。对，但在这种情况下，他们实际上可以操纵碰撞。换句话说，他们可以得到一些东西，不仅仅是随机的，而是他们想要与别的东西碰撞的东西。这就是它变得危险的地方。对，关于这一点的一个有趣的小插曲，他们在Chrome中放入了一个单元测试，其中存在一个碰撞。而且作为Chromium的一部分，我猜Chromium……我实际上不知道他们为什么把它作为单元测试，也许只是为了提醒人们永远不要使用SHA-1。但一旦他们放入那个单元测试，
there's a completely different image. They don't resemble each other at all. But if you run them through this SHA-1 algorithm for generating a hash, the hash will be identical. And what that means... Right, and they did it on purpose. Right, they found two different documents that collided.
并放入那两个PDF文件，它实际上破坏了Git。它字面上破坏了存储库，Chromium存储库瘫痪了近一周，因为Git看到了这两个具有相同SHA-1的文件，然后就崩溃了。是的，所以这很危险。你知道，他们在网站上……Git看到了这两个具有相同SHA-1的文件，然后就崩溃了。是的，所以这很危险。
Right, and yeah, and they can... And the important thing is that because you could generate just random data and hash it and then generate more random data and hash it, and eventually you'll get a collision right but in this case they can actually manipulate the collision so in other words like they can get something not just random but something they want to collide with something else and that's where it gets kind of dangerous right and a funny kind of side note on this they uh uh they put into chrome a unit test where there was a collision um and and so just as part of chromium and i guess chromium like uh i actually don't know why they put it as a unit test maybe it's just to remind people never to use SHA-1 but as soon as they put in that unit test
你知道，他们在网站上，我们会在节目笔记中链接它，他们列出了他们为实现这种碰撞投入了多少精力。但如果你仔细观察这些事情的趋势，每当这种算法被证明是脆弱的时候……所以长期以来人们一直说不要使用SHA-1，因为它接近脆弱，但没有人真正证明它……在这里确切地证明了有一个碰撞。现在他们有了，可能只需要几个月，也许一年，无论如何，计算成本会变得更低，你知道，也许几年，
and they put in those two PDF files it actually broke a git like it literally broke the repository and the chromium repository was down for like almost a week because git saw these two files with the same SHA-1 and just had a heart attack yeah so this is dangerous you know they have on the website Git saw these two files with the same SHA-1 and just had a heart attack. Yeah, so this is dangerous.
无论如何，这只是意味着基本上从现在开始，你应该预期这种情况会变得司空见惯，人们能够制造碰撞。所以使用SHA-1进行与安全相关的事情变得更加危险了。是的，这有点像WEP。你知道，有人黑了它，这是一个大事件。然后不到一年，就有了WEP攻击。就像你可以直接“sudo apt-get install wepattack”，然后得到任何你想要的WEP密码。
You know, they have on the website, we'll link it in the show notes, they have a list of how much effort they put into getting this collision. But if you sort of look through the trend of these things, whenever sort of algorithm like this is sort of proven to be vulnerable so a lot for a long time people have said don't use shaan one because it's close to being vulnerable but sort of no one had actually proven it to be like proven here definitively have a collision and now that they have it'll only probably be a matter of months maybe a year or whatever before the computation falls even cheaper and you know maybe a couple years or
而且它完全民主化了。是的。好了，节目推荐书时间。节目推荐书。我的节目推荐书是我从Audible听的第一本有声书。正如我在上一期节目中所说，因为看智能手机和电脑太多，我的眼睛有点疲劳。我决定注册一个Audible账户，听有声书，并在……时戴上那种不透明的面罩。
whatever it just means that basically any time now you should expect this to become commonplace where people are able to create collisions so using sha1 for something security related has just become much more dangerous yeah it's kind of like wep like wep you know someone hacked it you know it was a big deal. And, and then like less than a year later, there was WEP attack. Like you could just sudo apt-get install WEP attack and then get any WEP password you want.
我在公交车上。我那样做了，感觉真的很好。所以我的第一本有声书是Scott Adams，他是《呆伯特》（Dilbert）的创作者。他写了一本书叫《如何失败于几乎所有事情并仍然大获全胜：我的人生故事》。嗯，这很有趣。我的意思是，它读起来确实有点像自助手册。我的意思是，它确实是一本自助手册。它，你知道，他确实谈到了他的生活，也许只是因为我快读完了。但是，嗯，我一开始真的很感兴趣，它全是关于他的生活、他的磨难、他的苦难、他的心态，以及是什么让他度过了生命中不同的困难时期等等。但是书的后半部分全是关于……我猜是书名，
And it's just completely democratized. Yeah. All right. Well, time for book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show is my first audio book from Audible. As I said last show, I was getting kind of eye strain from too much smartphone, too much computer. And I decided to get an Audible account and listen to audio books and wear one of those opaque masks when
全是关于你，观众如何能在所有事情上失败并仍然大获全胜。那部分，嗯，你知道，它确实很有趣，但实际上也许是因为我老实说和Scott Adams有同样的心态，所以出于这个原因，我只是听到自己在说这些话，没有什么看起来对我那么有趣，因为我已经以同样的方式思考了。所以出于这个原因，也许，你知道，其他人可以从中获得更多，或者对其他人来说这是一本有争议的书。但我发现那部分对我来说有点无聊，但第一部分关于他的生活超级有趣。我一直很好奇，你知道，写漫画的人，他们的性格是什么样的，你确实得到了一个长长的
I'm on the bus. And I did that and it feels really good. And so my first audio book was Scott Adams, who's the creator of Dilbert. He wrote a book called How to Fail at Almost Everything and Still Win Big, the story of my life or kind of the story of my life. And, uh, it's interesting. I mean, it's, it definitely, you know, it reads kind of like a self-help kind of manual. I mean, it is a self-help kind of manual. It, you know, he does definitely talk about his life and maybe it's just because I'm getting, you know, to the end of it. But, uh, I really was interested in the beginning and it is all about his life, his trials, his tribulations, sort of his mentality, um, sort of what got him through the different hard parts in his life, et cetera. Um, but then the second half of the book is all about, uh, I guess the title of the book,
一瞥。所以是的，我完全推荐它。嗯，这是一次很棒的聆听体验，我对我的购买非常满意。我实际上通常有科幻小说推荐，除了我正在读一本非常长的书。所以我尽量不在读完书之前做推荐，尽管我知道我过去做过。所以我把那本留到下一期，那时我会读完那本书。所以相反，我不认为我曾经介绍过这个，
which is all about how you, how the audience can fail at everything and still win big and and that's the part that um you know it just it's you know like it's definitely interesting but it's actually maybe what it is is honestly i have a lot of the same mentality as as scott adams and so for this reason it's like i'm just hearing myself say things like like like nothing seems that interesting to me because i already think sort of the same way and so for that reason maybe you know someone else could uh get more out of it or maybe it's a contentious book to other people um but i found that part like a little boring for me but the first part is just super interesting about his life i always kind of wondered you know people who write comics sort of like what's kind of their persona and you definitely get a long
但我真的很喜欢《Make》杂志。《Make》杂志已经存在……哦，我甚至不知道有多久了，已经有一段时间了，很长一段时间。我一直……当我去书店看到我特别感兴趣的一期时，我会买下来，或者我会在线关注他们的博客。但它是……但我终于订阅了它，并开始在邮件中收到它，我真的很喜欢默认收到它，然后读完它，不管我是否认为我会读。
glimpse into that so yeah i totally recommend it um it was a great listen and uh i'm really happy with my purchase i actually normally have sci-fi recommendations, except that I'm in the middle of a really long book. And so I try to not do my recommendations until I finish with the book, although I know I have in the past. So I'm withholding that one until next episode, and I'll be finished with that book. So instead, I don't think I've ever covered this,
这很奇怪，因为我想我通常不读那么多纸质书或杂志，但我很喜欢这一本。《Make》杂志迎合了我猜他们帮助创造了名字的“创客”人群，即“创客运动”，也就是那些喜欢亲手制作东西，而不仅仅是从货架上购买东西的人。所以组装电子套件或制作电路、3D打印、制作自己的四轴飞行器，只是将艺术、技术、编码和电子产品混合在一起的整个范围。
but I really like make magazine and make magazine has been around oh i don't even know how long now for quite a while a long time and i've always sort of when i've gone to the bookstore and seen a copy of it that i was like particularly interested and i would pick it up or i would sort of follow their blog online um but it's But I finally got a subscription to it and just been receiving in the mail, which I really like just sort of getting it by default and then reading through it whether I sort of thought I would or not.
他们涵盖了所有这些东西，杂志本身我认为做得非常好。我不经常做我在里面发现的项目，但它仍然很鼓舞人心，即使我不做，读一读，看看他们描述某件事的方式，他们里面很酷的故事，他们推荐的工具，了解一下，你知道，嘿，人们最近在用Arduino或无线小PCB做什么？所以如果你还没看过，我相信大多数人可能听说过，但如果没有，如果你觉得你喜欢那种自己动手制作、
Which is weird because I guess I don't normally read that many in print books or magazines, but I'm enjoying this one. And Make Magazine caters to what i guess they sort of helped create the name for the maker crowd the maker movement which is to sort of say people who enjoy making things with their hands not just buying things off the shelf so putting together electrical kits or making circuits 3d printing making their own quadcopters just the whole gamut of sort of mixing art and technology and coding and electronics
尝试新事物、实验，一定要去看看。酷。所以这是……我猜，你能得到电子版还是只有纸质版？我相信……所以我有了纸质版，我想我只是认为这是一本做得非常好的纸质杂志，但我知道他们确实也有纸质版。我想我只是认为这是一本做得非常好的纸质杂志。
and they cover all of those things and the magazine itself is just sort of i think really well done i don't often do projects that i find in there, but it's still inspiring, even if I don't to sort of read through it and see the way they've described something and the cool stories they have in there and the tools they recommend and learning about sort of, you know, hey, what are people doing with Arduinos these days or with wireless sort of little PCBs? And so if you've not checked out, I'm sure most people have probably heard about it but if not and you feel like you're into that kind of do it yourself crafting
但我知道他们确实也有数字版。酷。非常酷。是的，所以你绝对可以得到，你知道，Patrick的百万小时有声书，或者你得到Scott Adams的有声书，那是八小时。八小时？那对我来说是一天的通勤时间。没错。不，那不是真的。在Audible上。所以你可以去audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，全部连在一起。
trying new things experimenting definitely check it out cool so this is I guess can you get an electronic version or it's only in print? I'm sure so I have the print version I guess I just think it's a really well done print magazine but I know they also do have the print version. I guess I just think it's a really well done print magazine.
我们有节目笔记中的链接。你可以开始听了。我觉得它很棒。它有一个非常酷的界面。哦，我注意到的一件事是Android上的界面比iOS好得多。我想是因为在iOS上，他们实际上不能把它作为应用内购买来销售，因为iOS，就像苹果，想要抽成。所以他们必须让你去网站。但是的，Android版本非常
But I know they also do have a digital version. Cool. Very cool. Yeah, so you can definitely get, you know, one of Patrick's mega million hour audio books or you get the Scott Adams audio book, which is eight hours. Eight hours? That's like one day of commuting for me. That's right. No, that's not true. On Audible. So you could go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown, all one
流畅。而且Android版本没有CIA在监视你，所以也有这一点。哦，实际上我甚至不知道那是否是真的，他们可能在两个版本上都在监视你。但哦，那太可怕了。如果你不……如果你对Audible不感兴趣，或者你已经有了账户，你也可以在Patreon上赞助我们。你所有的捐款都会以某种方式帮助节目。去年年底，我们多了一点钱，所以我们送出了一些免费的T恤。但要成为Patreon上的赞助商，你可以去patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。我们感谢你们所有的捐款和支持。是的，谢谢你们所有的帮助。所以我查了一下，我的有声书长度还差一点点就到46小时了。
word. We have a link in the show notes. And you can get started on that. I thought it was great. It's got a pretty cool interface. Oh, one thing I noticed is the interface on Android is way better than iOS. I think it's because on iOS, they can't actually sell it as an in-app purchase because iOS, like Apple, want to take a cut. So they have to sort of get you to go to the website. But yeah, the android version is is very
哇，那太紧张了。我只……我非常接近结尾了。哦，哇。所以是的，它是……是的，那太棒了。好的，那是下一次的预告。人们可能会去弄清楚那是什么，他们会说，哦，我知道。不，没人那么在乎。好的。节目工具。节目工具。我的节目工具是Tesseract。Tesseract很酷。
slick um and the android version doesn't have the cia spying on you so there's that too oh actually i don't even know if that's true they're probably spying on you on both of them but oh that was horrible if you if you don't uh if you're not interested in Audible or you already have an account, you can also sponsor us on Patreon. All of your donations go to help the show in some way. At the end of the year, last year, we had a bit extra, so we gave away some free t-shirts. But to be a sponsor on Patreon, you go to patreon.com slash programmingthrowdown. And we appreciate all of your donations and your support yes thank you for all the help so i checked my audiobook is just a little
它实际上是一家公司。哦，不，它是微软做的。然后微软有点放弃了它，谷歌接手了。从那以后它一直由谷歌维护。基本上，它是OCR。所以，OCR代表光学字符识别。所以，你可以给它一张图片，它会告诉你图片里的文字。现在，它是为书籍设计的。所以，你知道，你不能给它像街道……
bit shy of 46 hours in length wow that's intense i'm only i'm very close to the end oh wow so yeah it's uh yeah that's that's awesome okay, that's a teaser for next time. People will probably go figure out what it is and they'll be like, oh, I know. No, nobody cares that much. Okay. Tool of the show. Tool of the show. My tool of the show is Tesseract. Tesseract is pretty cool.
时长差一点点到46小时，哇，那太紧张了，我快要听完了，哦哇，是的，那太棒了，好的，那是下期的预告。人们可能会去找出那是什么，然后他们会说，哦，我知道了。不，没人那么在意。好的。本期工具。本期工具。我推荐的本期工具是Tesseract。Tesseract非常酷。
It actually was a company. Oh, no, it was done by Microsoft. Then Microsoft kind of abandoned it and Google picked it up. And it's been maintained by Google ever since. And basically, it's OCR. So, OCR stands for Optical Character Recognition. And so, you can give it an image, and it will tell you the text in the image. Now, it's meant for books. So, you know, you can't give it like a street
它实际上是一家公司。哦，不，它是微软开发的。后来微软放弃了它，谷歌接手了。从那以后一直由谷歌维护。基本上，它是OCR。所以，OCR代表光学字符识别。你可以给它一张图片，它会告诉你图片里的文字。现在，它是为书籍设计的。所以，你知道，你不能给它像街道这样的街道
corner with like a stop sign. It's not going to show you the word stop. You know, it's meant for a book where it's, you know, text and there's not really any background, right? With that said, though, it's extremely accurate. So, you could give it, you know, you could have a page. I don't know how it works with forms. Like it may or may not be accurate. I haven't tried that, but you could definitely give it a page from like a textbook that you've scanned or, you know, a letter that you've received that you've scanned. You can just take this, you can download Tesseract. You have it through a homebrew if you're a Mac user, or if you're on Linux, you have it through, you know, Apt or Yum or whatever package manager you're using.
角落里有一个像停车标志的东西。它不会显示“停止”这个词。你知道，它是为书设计的，也就是文字，背景里其实没什么东西，对吧？话虽如此，它非常准确。所以，你可以给它，你知道，你可以放一页。我不知道它处理表格的效果如何。它可能准确，也可能不准确。我还没试过，但你绝对可以给它一页你扫描过的教科书，或者，你知道，你收到并扫描过的一封信。你只需要拿这个，下载 Tesseract。如果你是 Mac 用户，可以通过 Homebrew 安装；如果你用的是 Linux，可以通过 Apt、Yum 或你正在使用的任何包管理器来安装。
If you're on Windows, you could probably download a binary. I don't know. But you get this Tesseract binary, and it's just as simple as saying, look, Tesseract and then the file name, and then boom, you know, you have the text. And it even tries to use sort of the spatial, it tries to be spatially aware. So if some of the text is center aligned, some of it's left aligned, it'll kind of pad with spaces. So for some things I was doing recently, I had like a bunch of images that I wanted to convert to text. And in my case, the images had a background, but I was able to sort of remove the background using some image processing.
如果你用的是 Windows，可能可以下载二进制文件。我不知道。但你得到了这个 Tesseract 二进制文件，使用起来就像说“看，Tesseract”然后加上文件名，砰，你知道，你就得到了文本。它甚至试图利用某种空间感，它试图在空间上保持感知。所以如果有些文本是居中对齐的，有些是左对齐的，它会用空格进行填充。所以对于我最近做的一些事情，我有一堆想要转换成文本的图像。在我的例子中，图像有背景，但我能够通过一些图像处理来去除背景。
So get it to where it was just the text. And it worked great. It just it just dumped out all the text for I had a lot of image. I mean, thousands of images. And it there was a couple of like weirdness thousands of images and it it uh you know there was a couple of like weirdness like you know there's like maybe one or two letters is off but uh it actually uses like also the knowledge of the language so so for example if these are english documents and you tell it english it will um you know take that into account. So if it thinks the word is T-H-I-M-K, but it knows that it's very close to think,
所以把它处理到只剩下文本。效果很好。它只是把所有的文本都导出来了，我有很多图像。我是说，成千上万张图像。它有一些奇怪的地方，成千上万张图像，它……你知道，有一些奇怪的地方，比如可能有一两个字母错了，但它实际上也利用了对语言的了解，所以例如，如果这些是英文文档，你告诉它是英语，它会……你知道，把这一点考虑进去。所以如果它认为这个词是 T-H-I-M-K，但它知道这非常接近 think，
which is an English word, it'll change it to think. So that fixed a lot of the errors. But yeah, if you ever need that, Tesseract is pretty cool. Will it do, you know, sort of like you said, scan where it is sort of aligned and flat well if you just sort of like take a picture with your cell phone will it you know kind of i mean i guess there's tools on your cell phone but if you just had pictures that you had snapped with the camera
这是一个英语单词，它会把它改成 think。所以这修复了很多错误。但是的，如果你需要这个，Tesseract 相当不错。它能做，你知道，就像你说的，扫描那种对齐且平整的文档吗？如果你只是用手机拍张照，它能……我的意思是，我想手机上有工具，但如果你只是拍了一些照片
or whatever and it wasn't sort of like uh properly aligned and it's sort of off center and there's some background oh yeah that's not a problem okay um that shouldn't be an issue yeah it's just what it can't do is like a street sign or something sure um but yeah if you have a document you've taken like or a check or something you've taken like a crooked picture it shouldn't be a problem cool mine is less useful but maybe more fun is uh pandemic the board game the app no uh the Pandemic nice board game made into an application an app for uh iOS and Android I checked that's available on both
或者其他什么，而且它没有那种……没有正确对齐，有点偏离中心，还有一些背景，哦，是的，那没问题，好的，嗯，那应该不是问题，是的，它唯一做不到的就是像路标之类的东西，当然，嗯，但如果你有一份文档，或者支票之类的，你拍了一张歪斜的照片，那应该没问题，酷，我的那个用处没那么大，但可能更有趣，是《瘟疫危机》这款桌游，不是应用程序，嗯，那个很棒的桌游被做成了一个应用程序，一个 iOS 和 Android 的应用，我查过了，两个平台上都有
it isn't free I think it was at this time two dollars on both um if you've never played Pandemic the board game I would recommend checking it out it's very fun if you're not into board games very much you've probably never played a board game i would recommend checking it out it's very fun if you're not into board games very much you've probably never played a board game like this it's what's known as a cooperative board
它不是免费的，我想当时两个平台上都是两美元，嗯，如果你从来没玩过《瘟疫危机》这款桌游，我建议你去看看，它非常有趣，如果你对桌游不太感兴趣，你可能从来没玩过像这样的桌游，它被称为合作类桌游
game which means each of the players who are playing you can play with i think uh you can play by yourself but you can play with i don't remember i think six people may be the limit i'm sorry i actually haven't played with other people the physical i think it's that much i think it's four but if you have the expansion it goes up to six if i remember okay that might be what i'm thinking about but okay so some number of other people but everybody is sort of on the same side on the same team in this case you're a set of researchers and scientists that are trying to cure viruses from that are infecting the world. And there are sort of rules for moving the game along where the viruses obey sort of certain rules of logic that the game tells you how to apply in cards that are used.
游戏，这意味着每个参与的玩家，你可以和……我想……你可以自己玩，但你可以和……我不记得了，我想六个人可能是上限，抱歉，我其实没和别人玩过，实体版我想是那么多，我想是四个人，但如果你有扩展包，如果我没记错的话，可以增加到六个人，好的，那可能是我在想的，但好的，所以是其他一些人，但每个人都在同一边，在同一个团队里，在这种情况下，你们是一组研究人员和科学家，试图治愈正在感染世界的病毒。而且游戏推进有一些规则，病毒遵循游戏告诉你如何在使用的卡牌中应用的某种逻辑规则。
And by playing those cards and obeying the rules that are in the rule book during the phase of the game's turn, the virus is sort of spread throughout the world. And that spreading in the rulebook during the phase of the game's turn the virus is sort of spread throughout the world and that's spreading throughout the world you have to combat with the other people on your team to try to rid the world of those viruses bacteria disease um and those pandemics and that board game is a lot of fun uh it's really highly rated. People really enjoy that game. Yeah, it's great. The app is a really good implementation of the board game.
通过打出这些卡牌并遵守游戏回合阶段规则手册中的规则，病毒会在世界各地传播。而这种在游戏回合阶段规则手册中的传播，病毒在世界各地传播，而这种在世界各地的传播，你必须与团队中的其他人并肩作战，试图将世界从那些病毒、细菌、疾病中解救出来，嗯，还有那些大流行病，那个桌游非常有趣，嗯，它的评价非常高。人们真的很喜欢那个游戏。是的，它很棒。这个应用程序是对这款桌游非常好的实现。
So I actually don't get a ton of time to play this with people because I just don't tend to actually get as much time to play board games as I'd really like. But I can still enjoy the board game by playing on my iPad or my iPhone. Can you play over the internet with friends i won't this sounds i don't want to make it sound sad or cheeky to say i don't know because i don't have friends but uh i don't i've not i i don't actually let me bring it up and see i've not tried you could you could just play with your face oh wait you have a facebook can you play with your oh you don't have a twitter account either i'm really bad i don't know i kind of enjoy i don't know a big multiplayer game person so i don't
所以我其实没有太多时间和别人玩这个，因为我往往没有我想象中那么多的时间去玩桌游。但我仍然可以通过在 iPad 或 iPhone 上玩来享受这款桌游。你可以通过互联网和朋友一起玩吗？我不会……这听起来……我不想让它听起来很悲伤或厚脸皮，说我不知道，因为我没有朋友，但嗯，我没有……我没有……我其实……让我调出来看看，我没试过，你可以……你可以只和你的……哦，等等，你有 Facebook，你可以和你的……哦，你也没有 Twitter 账号，我真的很糟糕，我不知道，我不太喜欢……我不是一个大型多人游戏玩家，所以我不知道
actually know oh it's asking me other questions i'm not sure i'm sure the internet can tell you this answer i did not come prepared you've stumped me i would definitely you know i think a game like this is kind of fun if you could play with like your family you know if each of you can just play on your own phone and it just goes round robin but it might take a long time to get through a game so you've played pandemic though before the board game yeah right okay cool yeah so have you played the the newer one where there's sort of like a meta game where stuff happens in between the games oh no so i think it's called uh pandemic legacy okay okay anyways for anyone out there who has played pandemic and enjoyed it there's
其实不知道，哦，它在问我其他问题，我不确定，我相信互联网能告诉你这个答案，我没准备好，你把我难住了，我绝对会……你知道，我觉得像这样的游戏如果能和家人一起玩会很有趣，你知道，如果你们每个人都可以在自己的手机上玩，然后轮流进行，但完成一局游戏可能需要很长时间，不过你以前玩过《瘟疫危机》桌游，对吧，好的，酷，是的，那么你玩过那种新的吗？就是有一种元游戏，在游戏之间会发生一些事情，哦，没有，所以我认为它叫《瘟疫危机：传承》，好的，好的，无论如何，对于任何玩过《瘟疫危机》并喜欢它的人来说，有
something called pandemic legacy and i've not played this before but this sort of what happens is you play and based on things that you choose to do or winning or losing against the viruses in the game, there's sort of envelopes and instructions that come along with the game that you open that modify the game and the game rules in sort of irreversible ways. And so people don't sort of like you won't find online exactly. I'm sure if you go digging, you can find it. But it sort of doesn't tell you what those are but it might be something like renaming a country or adding new connections or deleting connections i don't actually know i've not played it but you sort of end up physically altering the board that you have as you play these games you can't like go back so by the end of playing this sequence of games you have sort of like a customized board to your
一种叫《瘟疫危机：传承》的东西，我以前没玩过，但发生的事情是，你玩游戏，根据你选择做的事情，或者在游戏中战胜或输给病毒，游戏会附带一些信封和说明，你打开它们，以某种不可逆转的方式修改游戏和游戏规则。所以人们不会……就像你不会在网上找到确切的内容。我相信如果你去挖掘，你可以找到它。但它不会告诉你那些是什么，但它可能是像重命名一个国家，或者增加新的连接，或者删除连接，我其实不知道，我没玩过，但你最终会随着玩这些游戏而在物理上改变你拥有的棋盘，你不能回头，所以到玩完这一系列游戏结束时，你拥有了一个为你定制的棋盘
sequence it's almost like like campaigns indeed yes yeah so if you've not heard about that before people seem to really like that i haven't had a chance to play those because you sort of need to play it you know many times through over the course of several sessions but you kind of want to play with the same people so that you can kind of enjoy the unfolding together yeah makes sense super cool time to talk about cryptography cryptography you want to get us started well i thought i'd be a little cryptic and instead tell a story no okay the the thing instead You should be... Yeah, instead we're going to actually encrypt
序列，这几乎就像……就像战役一样，确实是的，是的，所以如果你以前没听说过，人们似乎真的很喜欢那个，我没有机会玩那些，因为你需要玩它，你知道，在几次会议的过程中玩很多次，但你想要和同样的人一起玩，这样你们就可以一起享受这种展开，是的，有道理，超级酷，是时候谈谈密码学了，密码学，你想让我们开始吗？嗯，我以为我会有点神秘，反而讲个故事，不，好的，那个……那个东西……你应该……是的，相反，我们要实际加密
this whole conversation. So from now and for the next 10 minutes, you'll only hear static. Yeah, it's only going to be pig Latin. Okay. Well, all joking aside, we're going to sort of give kind of a high-level overview of different parts of cryptography.
整个对话。所以从现在开始接下来的 10 分钟，你只会听到静电噪音。是的，只会是猪拉丁语。好的，不开玩笑了，我们要对密码学的不同部分做一个高层次的概述。
This is a huge field from the sort of practical standpoint of how do you encrypt stuff efficiently and where does it live in your code to the mathematical sort of proofs of robustness of various cryptography algorithms to i know just all sorts of things at every level. This is a very wide sweeping topic. And, you know, there's whole professions and fields that are, you know, sort of dedicated to the working with cryptography. And we're going to just sort of give it a high level overview in the kind of different aspects and parts.
这是一个巨大的领域，从如何高效加密数据以及它在代码中处于什么位置的实际角度，到各种密码算法稳健性的数学证明，我知道，各个层面都有各种各样的事情。这是一个非常广泛的话题。而且，你知道，有整个职业和领域是专门致力于研究密码学的。我们将对不同的方面和部分做一个高层次的概述。
And we'll probably miss a whole bunch. But the thing, cryptography is, you know, I won't give you, I don't know the like breakdown, the word crypto and graphic, but you know what cryptography is, is about,
我们可能会漏掉很多。但密码学，你知道，我不会给你……我不知道像分解“crypto”和“graphic”这个词，但你知道什么是密码学，它是关于，
I have some data and I don't want other people to know what that data is. So I have information that I want to keep secret or I want to give it to someone else and know that only they can read it. So Jason and I can communicate and only Jason and I know what's being said so that no one else can be a part of it or only the people we choose to be part of it are part of it. And the kind of most obvious way that people do this and is actually even still used and underlies a lot of the practical cryptography that's done today is sort of the shared secret so if i meet with jason in advance and whisper into his ear the password is i'm not going to share this on the podcast
我有一些数据，我不希望其他人知道这些数据是什么。所以我有一些我想保密的信息，或者我想把它给别人，并且知道只有他们能读懂。所以杰森和我可以交流，只有杰森和我才知道在说什么，这样其他人就不能参与其中，或者只有我们选择参与的人才能参与。人们做这件事最明显的方式，实际上甚至还在使用，并且构成了今天所做的大部分实际密码学的基础，就是所谓的共享秘密，所以如果我提前和杰森见面，在他耳边低语密码是……我不会在播客上分享这个
and then he you know writes that down on a piece of paper. And then I apply some algorithm using that secret to some data I have and send it to him. And then he knows in advance that secret. And he undoes it. Then he can read. I can know that only he can read it. And we've shared that secret. Sorry, we've shared that message. But we had to prearrange sharing that password.
然后他……你知道，把它写在一张纸上。然后我用那个秘密对我有的一些数据应用某种算法，然后发给他。然后他提前知道那个秘密。他解开它。然后他就能读了。我可以知道只有他能读懂。我们已经分享了那个秘密。抱歉，我们已经分享了那条消息。但我们必须预先安排好分享那个密码。
And that's tricky for a number of reasons. Because if we use the same password over and over and over again, we become at risk for people uncovering that by analyzing our data through various techniques. to meet in person and securely deliver that that's sort of expensive especially if i need to do this with many many people or i want to do it with someone who maybe is in a place it's difficult to get to um but having a shared secret and using it over and over again like we said it leaves you subject to sort of someone analyzing patterns and what you're sending and the solution to that that it's still used today is sort of known as like the one-time pad and this came from i guess one of the wars world war one world war two where there would literally be sort of a pad of of these shared secrets that two people would have and the passwords the things that you used to encoding were at very very long so that you that you sort of were more immune to this analysis and you only used it for sending one message. So if you sort of have a password that's
这在很多方面都很棘手。因为如果我们一遍又一遍地使用同一个密码，我们就会面临人们通过各种技术分析我们的数据来揭露它的风险。亲自见面并安全地传递它，这有点昂贵，特别是如果我需要和很多人这样做，或者我想和某个可能在难以到达的地方的人这样做，嗯，但拥有一个共享秘密并一遍又一遍地使用它，就像我们说的，会让你容易受到某种分析模式和发送内容的影响，而今天仍然使用的解决方案被称为“一次性密码本”，这来自我猜是战争时期，第一次世界大战，第二次世界大战，那时真的会有某种共享秘密的本子，两个人都会有，而密码，你用来编码的东西非常非常长，所以你对这种分析更免疫，而且你只用它发送一条消息。所以如果你有一种密码，它的长度
as long as your message and you only use it once, it is actually very simple to prove that it's impossible for someone who doesn't have that password to decode your message, because every message of that link is equally possible. Right. Like to give you like a visual example of this, right? Let's say you have like one of these 10 code passwords, you know, where it kind of looks like a telephone screen and you have the digits zero through nine and you have to punch in like, let's say a four digit password, right? So, you know, you type in the in like let's say a four digit password right so you know you type in the password let's say it's one two three four or something right so someone who's kind of watching you maybe they sit right next to the door they always see you kind of
和你的消息一样长，而且你只使用一次，那么证明对于没有那个密码的人来说，解码你的消息是不可能的，这实际上非常简单，因为该长度的每条消息都是同样可能的。对。就像给你一个视觉例子，对吧？假设你有这些 10 码密码之一，你知道，它看起来像一个电话屏幕，你有数字 0 到 9，你必须输入一个四位数的密码，对吧？所以，你知道，你输入……就像假设一个四位数的密码，对吧，所以你知道，你输入密码，假设是 1234 之类的，对吧？所以有人在观察你，也许他们就坐在门旁边，他们总是看到你做
doing kind of the same motion if they kind of see you enough times they can kind of pick up on what's going on or maybe um maybe even a better way of making the analogy is someone can kind of see you enough times, they can kind of pick up on what's going on. Or maybe even a better way of making the analogy is someone can kind of dust the area and they can see, oh, you know, the one, two, three, four buttons have like a lot of smudges on them. And maybe the one button is even more smudged because you got most of your finger oil on the one button. And so they can kind of like over time kind of reverse engineer the password, right? But if your password was like 30 digits long and you're punching, you know, all 10 of the digits three times in just a random order, that's going to be really, really hard. Like, like it's not like they can't use the same tricks I just described, right? So these one-time pads, these shared secrets, if you could sort of communicate them, they actually are sort of the goal of a lot of cryptography is to be able to sort of get to this because this is really robust.
同样的动作，如果他们看到足够多次，他们就能看出发生了什么，或者也许……也许更好的类比方式是有人能看到你足够多次，他们就能看出发生了什么。或者也许更好的类比方式是有人可以给该区域撒粉，他们可以看到，哦，你知道，1、2、3、4 按钮上有很多污迹。也许 1 号按钮上的污迹更多，因为你大部分手指油都在 1 号按钮上。所以他们可以随着时间的推移反向工程出密码，对吧？但如果你的密码有 30 位长，而且你输入，你知道，所有 10 个数字三次，只是随机顺序，那会非常非常困难。就像……并不是说他们不能使用我刚才描述的相同技巧，对吧？所以这些一次性密码本，这些共享秘密，如果你能交流它们，它们实际上是很多密码学的目标，因为这真的很稳健。
And so what you end up with a lot of this is how to share those one-time pads. This is also, we didn't really say this, but the idea is you want people to kind of be able to know how you're encrypting your data, how you're applying your cryptographic techniques. So the algorithm that you're using to encode your data should be able to be known. And even if people know that they still can't figure out what you're doing. That's like sort of a because otherwise you run into all sorts of other problems. But again, with this analysis, and in this particular one, these one time pads are symmetric. So
所以你最终得到很多关于如何共享这些一次性密码本的内容。这也是，我们没怎么说，但想法是你希望人们能够知道你是如何加密数据的，你是如何应用你的密码技术的。所以你用来编码数据的算法应该是可以被知道的。即使人们知道这一点，他们仍然无法弄清楚你在做什么。这就像是一种……因为否则你会遇到各种其他问题。但同样，通过这种分析，在这个特定的例子中，这些一次性密码本是对称的，所以
the thing that I do to my data,ason also does to his data to undo what i did and that's called symmetric key cryptography so that this sort of these one-time pads are both a shared secret and symmetric so that begs the question well what are alternatives and this is where you start to get to uh much more of what you hear today, which is public key cryptography. And public key cryptography means instead of making one key, I make two keys, one key that's public and one key that's private. And only I know my private key, but I can give away to the world my public key. And there's a lot of interesting things this unlocks. And it's sort of probably a little too difficult to explain the underlying algorithms of public key cryptography and the kind of how prime numbers are used as a part of this. I feel like that would get really confusing over podcasting. But when you hear words like RSA, cryptography, and then the pretty good privacy, the PGP
我对我的数据所做的事情，杰森也对他自己的数据做同样的事情来撤销我所做的，这被称为对称密钥密码学，所以这些一次性密码本既是共享秘密又是对称的，这就引出了一个问题，那么有什么替代方案呢？这就是你开始接触到……你今天听到的更多内容，也就是公钥密码学。公钥密码学意味着我不制作一个密钥，而是制作两个密钥，一个公钥和一个私钥。只有我知道我的私钥，但我可以把我的公钥给全世界。这解锁了很多有趣的事情。而且解释公钥密码学的底层算法以及质数是如何作为其中的一部分使用的，可能有点太难了。我觉得在播客上讲会变得非常混乱。但当你听到像 RSA、密码学，然后是 Pretty Good Privacy，PGP
set of tools also uses public key cryptography. And what it allows you to do is sort of a sequence of things. One is if I have data and I want to make sure that only Jason can read my data, I look up in a telephone book of sorts, Jason Gauci, his public key is, and you know, whatever it is. And I apply the algorithm with his key to my data. And I now know that the only person who can undo that is Jason, because this is an asymmetric encryption. So in order to, if you apply the encryption key again, you don't get a decrypted data.
工具集也使用公钥密码学。它允许你做的是一系列事情。第一，如果我有数据，我想确保只有杰森能读懂我的数据，我在某种电话簿里查找杰森·高奇，他的公钥是……你知道，不管是什么。我用他的密钥对我的数据应用算法。我现在知道唯一能解开它的人是杰森，因为这是非对称加密。所以为了……如果你再次应用加密密钥，你不会得到解密的数据。
You just get essentially garbled data. And so I apply his public key. I send it to Jason. Jason applies his private key. And then he can read my original plain text message, my unencrypted data. And so that solves as me, the sender, as Patrick, the sender to Jason, I now know that
你只会得到本质上乱码的数据。所以我应用他的公钥。我把它发给杰森。杰森应用他的私钥。然后他就能读懂我原始的纯文本消息，我未加密的数据。所以这解决了作为发送者，作为帕特里克，发送给杰森，我现在知道
only Jason can read my message. But when Jason receives the message, he doesn't actually yet know that Patrick sent it. So I can write in there at the end, you know, dash Patrick. But if Bob, I guess, yeah, okay, if Bob sent that message and just wrote dash Patrick at the end, Jason has actually no way of being able to tell that apart. And this is another awesome thing that public key cryptography allows you to do is what's called signing. And I'll see if I can get this correct and understandable.
只有杰森能读懂我的消息。但当杰森收到消息时，他实际上还不知道是帕特里克发的。所以我可以在最后写上，你知道，破折号帕特里克。但如果鲍勃，我猜，是的，好的，如果鲍勃发了那条消息，只是在最后写了破折号帕特里克，杰森实际上没有任何办法能分辨出来。这是公钥密码学允许你做的另一件很棒的事情，叫做签名。我会看看我能否把它讲得正确且易懂。
So when I go to sign a message, so I write my letter out, dear Jason, you're really awesome, dash Patrick. And then I apply his public, I apply his every day. Yes, I make sure to send you one every day because no one else is going to. Oh, dang. So I write that message. I apply his public key using the algorithm. I encrypt that data. Now I want to have him be able to verify that it's for me. So we talked about SHA-1 hashing before. And that's not secure, so don't use that. But assume you use some other kind of hashing that's secure. SHA-5 or something. Yeah. So, and you, and you take the hash. So some representation of the data that is reasonably easy to believe that no one else could sort of change the data in any way. You take that hash. And then now I do something a little bit weird. I take my private key and I sign,
所以当我签名一条消息时，我写下我的信，亲爱的杰森，你真的很棒，破折号帕特里克。然后我应用他的公钥，我应用他的……每天。是的，我确保每天给你发一条，因为没有别人会发。哦，该死。所以我写下那条消息。我使用算法应用他的公钥。我加密那些数据。现在我想让他能够验证它是来自我的。所以我们之前谈过 SHA-1 哈希。那是不安全的，所以不要使用它。但假设你使用某种其他安全的哈希。SHA-5 之类的。是的。所以，你……你取哈希。所以是对数据的一种表示，有理由相信没有其他人能以任何方式更改数据。你取那个哈希。然后现在我做了一些有点奇怪的事情。我用我的私钥签名，
I apply using the same algorithm as before to encrypt the data I encrypt the hash with my private key now I take the original message that's encrypted with Jason's public key the hash which is encrypted with my private key and I send those to get oh I guess actually sorry not the encrypted data the unencrypted data and then my sign and then I encrypt that whole thing because I don't want other people to be able to see that. So I want to encrypt the whole thing. I send the whole encrypted thing to Jason. Jason applies his private key to the whole message. So now he can see, Jason, you're awesome, dash Patrick. But he doesn't actually know it came from me yet. He has a bunch of sort of still encrypted data at the bottom. And he goes,
我使用和之前相同的算法来加密数据，我用我的私钥加密哈希，现在我取用杰森公钥加密的原始消息，用我的私钥加密的哈希，然后我把它们发给……哦，我猜其实抱歉，不是加密的数据，是未加密的数据，然后是我的签名，然后我把整个东西加密，因为我不希望其他人能看到它。所以我想加密整个东西。我把整个加密的东西发给杰森。杰森对整个消息应用他的私钥。所以现在他能看到，杰森，你很棒，破折号帕特里克。但他实际上还不知道它来自我。他在底部有一堆某种仍然加密的数据。他说，
oh, I want to make sure this came from Patrick. So he goes and looks up in the phone book of keys. He looks up Patrick, my public key, and he applies that to the encrypted data at the bottom of the message. He sees that now he has what he believes is a hash. So he hashes the decoded message that I sent him. And he compares that with the now unencry believes is a hash. So he hashes the decoded message that I sent him. And he compares that with the now unencrypted, hopefully, hash. And if they match, he knows that that message came from me, is only read by him,
哦，我想确保这来自帕特里克。所以他去查找密钥电话簿。他查找帕特里克，我的公钥，并把它应用到消息底部加密的数据上。他看到现在他有了他认为是哈希的东西。所以他对他发给我的解码消息进行哈希处理。并将它与现在未加密的……希望是哈希进行比较。如果它们匹配，他就知道那条消息来自我，只有他能读到，
and nobody can have changed it. And that's sort of like the awesome part of public key cryptography or one of the many awesome things that allows you to do. And that's basically, in a nutshell, how everything on on the internet works like if you go on the internet this month and you pay your bills the only reason you can do that is because of what patrick just said yep so ssl encryption relies on this to uh be able to send your data securely sshing if you
而且没有人能更改它。这就像是公钥密码学很棒的部分，或者它允许你做的许多很棒的事情之一。这基本上就是互联网上一切运作的方式，就像如果你这个月上网并支付账单，你唯一能做到这一点的原因就是因为帕特里克刚才说的，是的，SSL 加密依赖于此来……能够安全地发送你的数据，SSH，如果你
ssh into your computer also uses these techniques this is very very widely used yep yeah whenever you see that little lock icon on the browser on the on the top left which now you should see almost everywhere um um that means that this this technique is in play like it's just i mean it mean, it sounds complicated. I mean, and it is, but I mean, it's happening so fast that you don't even notice, but it's actually a lot going on and it's, it's every single packet is being encrypted in this way. So, I mean, this is happening. If you go to even just like google.com or something, this is happening thousands of times. So maybe not thousands, but hundreds. Well, so yeah, you know, what I just described and I said these phone books, if you hear about sort of the certificate authorities that come up a lot recently with in regards
SSH 进入你的电脑也使用这些技术，这非常非常广泛地使用，是的，是的，每当你看到浏览器左上角那个小锁图标时，现在你应该几乎到处都能看到，嗯……这意味着这项技术正在发挥作用，就像它只是……我的意思是，它听起来很复杂。我的意思是，它确实很复杂，但我的意思是，它发生得太快了，你甚至没有注意到，但实际上有很多事情在发生，而且，每一个数据包都以这种方式被加密。所以，我的意思是，这正在发生。如果你甚至只是去 google.com 之类的地方，这正在发生数千次。所以也许不是数千次，但几百次。好吧，所以是的，你知道，我刚才描述的，我说这些电话簿，如果你听说过最近关于 SSL 的证书颁发机构，
to SSL, those are about sort of the phone book of trusted companies. So that's where my browser can go to verify that Google's a site I go to on Google is actually coming from Google. A site I go to from Amazon is actually from Amazon, at some point there has to be something to get it started. Right. And the trust that gets the whole thing started, as Patrick said, are these stores. So like there's a whole bunch of work going into making sure that you get these public keys safely and securely. And then the only other thing that I think is sort of interesting here, and then we'll move on from this part, is to say that these algorithms, these public key cryptography algorithms are pretty slow. Like they're not very efficient, both in this sort of generating keys is very expensive, but actually encoding messages this way is very costly. And so what you normally try to do is minimize the data you need to exchange this way and then this goes back to the one-time pad we talked about before so actually what you want to do is exchange in the encrypted something you've encrypted with one-time pads but now i have a way to share my one-time pad with jason so i can use this public key stuff we just talked about to send him a one
那些是关于某种受信任公司的电话簿。所以这就是我的浏览器可以去验证我访问的谷歌网站实际上来自谷歌的地方。我从亚马逊访问的网站实际上来自亚马逊，在某个时候必须有东西来启动它。对。而启动这一切的信任，正如帕特里克所说，是这些商店。所以，有很多工作投入到确保你安全可靠地获得这些公钥。然后我认为这里还有一件有趣的事情，然后我们将从这一部分继续，那就是说这些算法，这些公钥密码算法相当慢。就像它们效率不高，生成密钥非常昂贵，但以这种方式编码消息实际上成本非常高。所以你通常尝试做的是最小化你需要以这种方式交换的数据，然后这回到了我们之前谈到的一次性密码本，所以实际上你想做的是交换加密的东西，你用一次性密码本加密的东西，但现在我有办法和杰森分享我的一次性密码本，所以我可以使用我们刚才谈到的公钥来给他发一个
time pad encryption and then i can use that which is very very fast to encrypt the rest of my data yep but then every time jason and i communicate we exchange a one-time pad right yep um cool so let's talk a little bit about um the encryption so you have a key and let's see me sort of exchange that key correctly and all of that. Now you have some data like you have, you know, every month I have a cron job that that sends Patrick an email saying he's amazing because, you know, I don't have time to do that. I did mine personally, but yours is a cron job. I see where I lay in this stack. And so that, so I need to, I need to encrypt that somehow. Like I need to take my key
一次性密码本加密，然后我可以使用它，它非常非常快，来加密我其余的数据，是的，但每次杰森和我交流时，我们都会交换一个一次性密码本，对吧，是的，嗯，酷，让我们谈谈……加密，所以你有一个密钥，让我们看看我是否正确交换了那个密钥等等。现在你有一些数据，就像你有，你知道，每个月我都有一个 cron 任务，给帕特里克发一封电子邮件，说他很棒，因为，你知道，我没时间做那个。我亲自做了我的，但你的是一个 cron 任务。我看到了我在这个堆栈中的位置。所以那个，所以我需要，我需要以某种方式加密它。就像我需要拿我的密钥
and take this plain text and I need to apply the key and turn the plain text into something that looks unintelligible until it's decrypted. Right. Um, so, you know, there's, there's this, this idea of doing this has been around for extremely long time. Um, so, you know, there's, there's this, this idea of doing this has been around for extremely long time. Um, there's something called the Caesar cipher, which correct me if I'm wrong, but it actually comes from, because it came from the days of Julius Caesar. I'm pretty sure that that that's actually accurate. And, uh, what it involves is basically applying a certain number.
拿这个纯文本，我需要应用密钥，把纯文本变成看起来难以理解的东西，直到它被解密。对。嗯，所以，你知道，有……有这种做这件事的想法已经存在很长时间了。嗯，所以，你知道，有……有这种做这件事的想法已经存在很长时间了。嗯，有一种东西叫凯撒密码，如果我没记错的话，它实际上来自……因为它来自尤利乌斯·凯撒时代。我很确定那是准确的。而且，嗯，它涉及的基本是应用一个特定的数字。
So the key in this case is just a number, like let's say five, right? And what you do then is you take your message, which assume it's all letters, and you rotate all the letters by five. So what that means is A becomes B, C, D, A becomes F, B becomes G, C becomes H, and it rolls over. So Z becomes E, right? Now, if the number was negative 5, you'd rotate in the other direction. If the number was 26, that would be a bad choice. You would not do any rotation, and the person would just see your plain text, right?
所以这种情况下的密钥只是一个数字，比如五，对吧？然后你做的是你拿你的消息，假设它全是字母，你把所有字母旋转五位。这意味着 A 变成 B，C，D，A 变成 F，B 变成 G，C 变成 H，并且它会循环。所以 Z 变成 E，对吧？现在，如果数字是负 5，你会向另一个方向旋转。如果数字是 26，那将是一个糟糕的选择。你不会做任何旋转，对方只会看到你的纯文本，对吧？
A similar idea is a substitution cipher, which is a little bit more sophisticated. In this case, you're not doing, you know, that same rotation to every letter, but you use your key to generate a mapping. So you could say, you know, A is G. So wherever I see an A in this encrypted or unencrypted text, wherever I see an A, I turn it into a G. And then now when I have the encrypted text and whenever I see a G, because I have the key, which tells me sort of the mapping, I'll go back and change it back to an A and I'll get my original message back. These ciphers are totally stateless, right? Like if you have the key, then you could just apply that key and you could decode half the message.
一个类似的想法是替换密码，它稍微复杂一点。在这种情况下，你不是对每个字母做……你知道，同样的旋转，但你使用你的密钥来生成一个映射。所以你可以说，你知道，A 是 G。所以无论我在这个加密或未加密的文本中看到 A，无论我在哪里看到 A，我都把它变成 G。然后现在当我有了加密文本，无论我在哪里看到 G，因为我有密钥，它告诉了我某种映射，我会回去把它改回 A，我会得到我的原始消息。这些密码完全是无状态的，对吧？就像如果你有密钥，那么你就可以直接应用那个密钥，你就可以解码一半的消息。
You could decode the end of the message. It doesn't matter, right? But they're also extremely weak for this reason, right? Like for example, if I have this huge message, let's say I encrypt like a huge document, right? I know that the word the is very common, T-H-E, that that word is very common in English. So if I see, you know, in the encrypted message, if I see a bunch of three-letter words, I could say, oh, that's probably the. So let me like apply my substitution cipher and let me see kind of how the rest of the document looks. And I can keep
你可以解码消息的结尾。没关系，对吧？但它们也因为这个原因非常脆弱，对吧？就像例如，如果我有这条巨大的消息，假设我加密了一个巨大的文档，对吧？我知道“the”这个词非常常见，T-H-E，那个词在英语中非常常见。所以如果我看到，你知道，在加密消息中，如果我看到一堆三个字母的单词，我可以说，哦，那可能是“the”。所以让我……应用我的替换密码，让我看看文档的其余部分看起来如何。我可以继续
kind of playing around with sort of my innate knowledge of language and then end up with a substitution and end up like reverse engineering the cipher. So stateless ciphers are bad. And so people started making stateful ciphers. So, for example, what I can do is I can say I'm going to encrypt this block of data using my key. But then what comes out of the encryption is the encrypted text, but then also some other numbers. And now when I go to encrypt the second block of data, I'm going to use those numbers. And even if the second block is exactly the same as the first, those numbers that came from the first block are going to make the second block look different, right? Think of it as like different inputs, right? And so now my trick that I just described,
某种程度上玩弄我对语言的内在知识，然后最终得到一个替换，并最终像反向工程出密码一样。所以无状态密码很糟糕。所以人们开始制作有状态密码。所以，例如，我可以做的是，我可以用我的密钥加密这块数据。但加密出来的是加密文本，还有一些其他数字。现在当我去加密第二块数据时，我将使用那些数字。即使第二块和第一块完全一样，那些来自第一块的数字也会让第二块看起来不同，对吧？把它想成是不同的输入，对吧？所以现在我刚才描述的那个技巧，
where I find all the does, that trick doesn't work anymore because the gets encrypted differently in the first block in the second. And so, you know, everyone's kind of moved on to stateful ciphers. And there's the block-based approach I just described. And there's even, they have a way where you can actually do a streaming cipher. So you can, you know, it doesn't have to be broken up into these chunks and it can still take advantage of that sort of trick. And just as sort of trivia, that extra data that gets kept around from block to block, that's called the nonce. You can also start with a non-zero nonce,
我找到所有的“the”，那个技巧不再起作用了，因为“the”在第一块和第二块中被加密的方式不同。所以，你知道，每个人都转向了有状态密码。有我刚才描述的基于块的方法。甚至还有一种方法，你可以实际做一个流密码。所以你可以，你知道，它不必被分成这些块，它仍然可以利用那种技巧。作为一种琐事，从一块到另一块保留的额外数据，那被称为随机数（nonce）。你也可以从非零随机数开始，
but you have to agree to it. So I could tell Patrick, hey, I'm going to start my nonce with five. And then we both know the first block is going to have my key and then five. And then the second block is going to be, you know, different based on the content of the first block. And so most people use stateful ciphers, right? But the key thing here is if you want to do cryptography, like if you're building an app and you want to send something securely, and let's assume you're not using SSH or HTTP, like you're writing your own custom thing. The answer here is use Libsodium.
但你必须同意它。所以我可以告诉帕特里克，嘿，我要用 5 开始我的随机数。然后我们都知道第一块将有我的密钥，然后是 5。然后第二块将是，你知道，根据第一块的内容而不同。所以大多数人使用有状态密码，对吧？但这里的关键是，如果你想做密码学，就像如果你正在构建一个应用程序，你想安全地发送一些东西，让我们假设你没有使用 SSH 或 HTTP，就像你在写你自己的自定义东西。这里的答案是使用 Libsodium。
So Libsodium is an open source library um it was put together by i think like google and facebook and a bunch of companies and uh that's it basically lib sodium has an encrypt and a decrypt function um they let you specify the nonce or leave it out but but use that library don't ever ever ever write your own cryptography library. Like even if you look at the source code for AES or Salsa20 and say, oh, I could write that myself, don't do it. Because if you have a bug, it's gonna end very badly, right? Like someone like, if you need something to be secure,
所以 Libsodium 是一个开源库，嗯，它是由我想是谷歌和脸书以及一堆公司放在一起的，嗯，就是这样，基本上 Libsodium 有一个加密和一个解密函数，嗯，它们让你指定随机数或者留空，但……使用那个库，永远永远永远不要写你自己的密码库。就像即使你查看 AES 或 Salsa20 的源代码，说，哦，我自己也能写出来，不要这样做。因为如果你有一个错误，它会以非常糟糕的方式结束，对吧？就像有人……如果你需要某样东西是安全的，
then chances are there's consequences to it not being secure. Like maybe it hurts your business or your whole product is ruined or something. Right. And it's just not worth taking that risk for no reason, right? Like Libsodium is an amazing library. The API is very simple. It's, um, constantly being peer reviewed and, uh, yeah, when it gets to the nuts and bolts of it, just use LipSodium. And that's pretty much it.
那么很有可能它不安全会有后果。就像也许它伤害了你的生意，或者你的整个产品被毁了之类的。对。而且为了毫无理由地承担那个风险是不值得的，对吧？就像 Libsodium 是一个很棒的库。API 非常简单。它，嗯，不断地被同行评审，而且，嗯，是的，当涉及到它的细节时，只管使用 Libsodium。基本上就是这样。
I think it's really easy to introduce, like we talked about all these steps. So Jason was talking about this stateful cipher where I was talking about exchanging one-time pads. But obviously you might want to send more data than the size of your password. And so you need to do all of this extra stuff to avoid these very, very clever and sophisticated attacks. And I think what Jason is pointing out is like, if you do this on your own, you're likely to sort of introduce some sort of bad assumption or a bug, a mistake, something you think or won't even know to check for. And someone sort of looking around and figuring this out could leave you very vulnerable.
我认为引入它真的很容易，就像我们谈到的所有这些步骤。所以杰森在谈论这个有状态密码，而我当时在谈论交换一次性密码本。但显然你可能想发送比你的密码大小更多的数据。所以你需要做所有这些额外的事情来避免这些非常、非常聪明和复杂的攻击。而且我认为杰森指出的是，如果你自己做这件事，你很可能会引入某种错误的假设或错误、失误，一些你认为甚至不知道要检查的东西。而有人四处查看并弄清楚这一点可能会让你非常脆弱。
And so, yeah, I agree. Do not do this on your own, even if it seems really easy. Libsodium has bindings for almost every language because everyone else is in the same boat. And yeah, there's really no reason to not use it i'll also see the above talk about you know things that have come out from wiki leaks about why you don't want to be using something that could be vulnerable and it's better for someone else to keep track of sort of the current best practices and help keep you secure. Yep. So one of the things that you also hear about cryptography, and we'll cover this, you know,
所以，是的，我同意。不要自己做这件事，即使它看起来真的很容易。Libsodium 几乎为每种语言都有绑定，因为其他人都在同一条船上。而且是的，真的没有理由不使用它，我也会看到上面谈论的，你知道，维基解密发布的东西，关于为什么你不想使用可能容易受到攻击的东西，让别人跟踪当前的最佳实践并帮助保持你的安全会更好。是的。所以你听到的关于密码学的另一件事，我们将涵盖这个，你知道，
sort of only at a high level, is all the stuff we've talked about works together to keep you secure, but very, very determined people with lots and lots of time on their hands still have a very good chance of being able to get at your data after some amount of time, right? The amount of time it takes, it's kind of the equivalent as if you, you know, have some valuables in your house, you know, some jewelry or whatever, and you put it in a safe. You don't want to sort of have a bank vault grade safe for what amounts to, you know, a couple thousand dollars in jewelry,
某种程度上只在高层次上，是我们谈到的所有东西一起工作来保持你的安全，但非常有决心、有大量时间的人仍然有很好的机会在一段时间后能够获取你的数据，对吧？它花费的时间量，这有点等同于如果你，你知道，在你的房子里有一些贵重物品，你知道，一些珠宝什么的，你把它放在保险箱里。你不想为价值几千美元的珠宝准备一个银行金库级别的保险箱，
because you spend a million dollars on a safe to protect a thousand dollars. It doesn't make a lot of sense. Your jewelry isn't that valuable. And the cost of the safe is partly because of the size, but also sort of rated for how long it would take someone to break into that safe. And the thought is with enough time and money and dedication, someone will always be able to get into the safe. But hopefully, you know, the stuff you're storing inside isn't worth that amount of effort, then it's sort of secure. And the same kind of applies for a lot of this encryption stuff. This is based on work that has to be done. And the work that has to be done to undo the encryption
因为你花了一百万美元买一个保险箱来保护一千美元。这没什么意义。你的珠宝没那么值钱。而且保险箱的成本部分是因为尺寸，但也某种程度上取决于有人闯入那个保险箱需要多长时间。而想法是，有足够的时间、金钱和奉献精神，总有人能进入保险箱。但希望，你知道，你存放在里面的东西不值得那么大的努力，那么它某种程度上就是安全的。同样的事情也适用于很多这种加密东西。这是基于必须完成的工作。而必须完成的工作来撤销加密
is much, much bigger than the work done to do the encryption when it's done carefully. And all of these techniques that we've talked about doing to try to make things better are about making sure that holds true, that the amount of work to decrypt is disproportionately larger than the amount of work to do the encryption.
远大于精心加密所做的工作。我们谈到的所有这些旨在改善现状的技术，都是为了确保这一点成立，即解密所需的工作量远大于加密所需的工作量。
But if there turns out to be a problem in your algorithm or a problem in your data, and that assumption breaks, now people can get at your data much more quickly. Also, as computers sort of become faster and faster, if you sort of, and this is where you hear like the number of bits of encryption, but the number of bits of encryption that were were used you know a decade ago computers and gpus and fpgas and asics of today can break those much much much more quickly today so it maybe takes an hour of computing an hour of computing time today to break what would have taken years before and so what jason was sort of alluding to um before when he was talking about uh oh what were you saying oh it slipped my mind you were saying something where uh uh not to use your own
但如果你的算法或数据出现问题，导致这一假设失效，那么人们就能更快地获取你的数据。此外，随着计算机速度越来越快，你可能听说过加密位数这个概念，但十年前使用的加密位数，现在的计算机、GPU、FPGA 和 ASIC 都能更快地破解。以前需要几年时间才能破解的东西，现在可能只需要一小时的计算时间。这就是杰森之前提到的，呃，你刚才说的是什么？我忘了，你提到不要使用你自己编写的……
crypto ah it's gone oh well jason had a good point related to that before uh but when you're setting how big these are you want to sort of think about the best practices of today. But the thought is in 100 years, who knows what's going to happen? And you don't know if your day is going to be secure. And one of the things people talk about that would cause a lot of problems in this assumption of it taking a long time to decrypt your data is quantum computers. And we don't have time to sort of go into the details of this. But the idea is that quantum computers can do the de-encryption calculations very, very quickly in parallel. And at some point, if quantum computers become, which not everyone agrees
加密算法，啊，我想起来了。好吧，杰森之前在这方面提出了一个很好的观点。但在设定这些参数大小时，你需要考虑当今的最佳实践。但问题是，100 年后会发生什么？谁也不知道。你无法确定你的数据是否安全。人们谈论的一个会导致这一假设（解密需要很长时间）出现问题的因素是量子计算机。我们没有时间深入探讨细节，但其核心思想是量子计算机可以并行地非常快速地进行解密计算。在某种程度上，如果量子计算机成为现实——虽然并非所有人都同意
they ever will reach this, but if quantum computers became sophisticated enough, they would sort of be able to almost instantaneously decrypt the data that we use today, because of their ability to, in parallel, run a lot of the math computations that are necessary to decrypt data. And so you'll hear people say this, like, oh, quantum computers will sort of be able to undo this. And that's what they're sort of saying is quantum computers can do a bunch in parallel and they'll be able to decrypt these much more quickly. It is also like just to like try to illustrate it as best I can. like a bunch of different uh uh you know keys in parallel and then returns the one that has the most number like instances of the word duh and uh you could fire this off and then the quantum uh processes that have that end up you know decrypting something with a lot of does in it
它们一定会达到这种程度——但如果量子计算机变得足够先进，它们几乎可以瞬间解密我们今天使用的数据，因为它们能够并行运行解密数据所需的许多数学计算。所以你会听到人们说，哦，量子计算机将能够破解这些加密。他们所说的就是量子计算机可以并行处理大量任务，从而更快地解密。为了尽可能形象地说明，就像同时尝试大量不同的密钥，然后返回包含最多“duh”字样的那个。你可以启动这个过程，然后那些拥有该结果的量子进程最终会解密出包含大量“duh”的内容。
will start to like bubble to the top and uh you're using sort of this trick you can you can uh try like two to the n keys in n time and uh and break almost any password it's all kind of very pie in the sky theoretical stuff but that's that's sort of the idea and then you'll also hear that typically immediately followed up with, but quantum computers will also make, hopefully for the first time, unbreakable encryption. And what people say there is there's sort of some interesting properties of the way quantum mechanics works that if things pan out,
并开始浮出水面。你利用这种技巧，可以在 n 时间内尝试 2 的 n 次方个密钥，并破解几乎任何密码。这听起来很遥远且理论化，但这就是基本思路。你还会听到人们紧接着说，量子计算机也有望首次实现不可破解的加密。人们所说的是，量子力学的工作方式有一些有趣的特性，如果一切顺利的话，
you'd be able to encrypt your data using these sort of quantum properties in a way that if someone ever tried to tamper with your data or use the wrong key, that the message would sort of self-destruct. So trying the wrong key on your quantum encrypted data, I'm being very loose with the words here, but like trying the wrong key against it would sort of make it explode if it wasn't right.
你将能够利用这些量子特性来加密数据，这样如果有人试图篡改你的数据或使用错误的密钥，消息就会自毁。所以，在你的量子加密数据上尝试错误的密钥——我这里用词比较随意——就像是如果密钥不对，它就会爆炸。
And so you would never try unless you knew you had the right key because the data would just be destroyed otherwise. And it isn't like you can copy the data and try it again because of these quantum properties. You can't copy the data many, many times and just keep trying and destroying them until you find the right one.
所以除非你确定拥有正确的密钥，否则你永远不会尝试，因为否则数据就会被销毁。而且你不能复制数据再试一次，因为这些量子特性。你无法多次复制数据并不断尝试，直到找到正确的密钥。
No, you're sort of guaranteed that that message only exists once and that can only attempt to be unlocked once. Right, exactly. Yeah, you create sort of this entanglement and when you make the copy, if you try a bad key on the copy, you'll destroy both copies at the same time
不，你基本上可以保证该消息只存在一份，并且只能尝试解锁一次。没错，正是这样。是的，你创造了一种纠缠，当你进行复制时，如果你在副本上使用了错误的密钥，你就会同时销毁两个副本。
because they're sort of, they're binded together bound together um yeah so that's that's some pretty cool stuff that may come you know in our lifetime may not we'll see um one thing that just as like a final takeaway is um if your client is compromised you're hosed like if you get a virus on your laptop, you're done, dude. Like there is no cryptography that's going to help you. Like if you get a virus, that virus could just say, oh, I'm VeriSign now. And like all my public keys are this. And, you know, oh, you thought you're going to CapitalOne.com, but you're actually going to my website, right? Like, and so, you know, one of the things that came out of the WikiLeaks was that they cracked like all of the end-to-end encryption
因为它们是绑定在一起的。是的，这确实是很酷的东西，可能在我们有生之年实现，也可能不会，我们拭目以待。最后一点要提醒的是，如果你的客户端被攻破，你就完了。如果你笔记本电脑中了病毒，你就彻底完了。没有任何加密能帮到你。如果中了病毒，病毒可以直接说：“哦，我现在是 VeriSign 了”，然后我所有的公钥都是这个。而且，你以为你要去 CapitalOne.com，但实际上你去了我的网站。所以，维基解密泄露出来的一件事就是他们破解了所有的端到端加密，
like whatsapp and and iMessage and all these things that have end-to-end encryption the the government was able to crack it that's not true at all basically all of those cryptography um techniques are not cracked but what they did is crack the client like if if you crack if someone's typing a message to someone else and you've hacked their phone you can just see what they're typing before the message is even sent right so that data is kept that data is kept in memory unencrypted. So either once it's been decrypted or before it's been encrypted, it's in memory in plain text and they can just look at it there if they are able to run processes on your system.
比如 WhatsApp、iMessage 以及所有这些具有端到端加密功能的东西。政府能够破解它，这完全不是事实。基本上所有这些加密技术都没有被破解，但他们所做的是破解了客户端。如果有人正在给别人发消息，而你黑进了他们的手机，你可以在消息发送之前就看到他们正在输入的内容。所以这些数据在内存中是未加密的。无论是在解密后还是在加密前，它都以明文形式存在于内存中，如果他们能在你的系统上运行进程，他们就可以直接查看。
Exactly, yeah. So if your system, so cryptography will not help you at all if your system is compromised. And with that in mind, like if you have a virus or something on your computer um like don't even open your browser to uh find out how to remove it like use your phone or something um because you know anything can cause you to give all of your personal data at that point all right well that was sort of a high level man cryptography has a lot of parts i don't even think we covered there's tons of stuff i'm still thinking like oh we didn't cover this and we didn't cover yeah i know i mean yeah we could definitely talk about all the different
没错。所以如果你的系统被攻破，加密技术根本帮不了你。考虑到这一点，如果你的电脑中了病毒，甚至不要打开浏览器去查找如何清除它，使用你的手机或其他设备，因为任何操作都可能导致你在那一刻泄露所有个人数据。好吧，这只是一个大概的概述。天哪，加密技术涉及的内容太多了，我觉得我们甚至还没讲完。还有很多东西，我还在想，哦，我们没讲这个，也没讲那个。是的，我知道，我们可以讨论所有不同的
algorithms and but uh um but you know i think that um you kind of gave everyone a high level gave gave you all a high level um definitely go on wikipedia um if you're interested it's it's a fascinating subject there's a lot to cover yeah i mean i'm always i don't know i guess in computer science you sort of are in and around in cryptography so much that you kind of bump up against it you sort of read a little bit out you sort of learn a little more you go a little ways you learn a little bit more and i always sort of am fascinated like i kind of want to deep dive into it but i've never really had that opportunity but over time i guess yeah you just really build up a lot of sort of peripheral
算法，但我认为我们已经给大家提供了一个大概的概述。如果你感兴趣，一定要去维基百科看看，这是一个引人入胜的主题，有很多内容。是的，在计算机科学领域，你经常会接触到加密技术，你会读一点，学一点，再深入一点，学得更多。我一直很着迷，想深入研究，但一直没有机会。但随着时间的推移，我想你确实积累了很多外围的
knowledge about it when working in computer science yeah Yeah, I mean, I did my own. Actually, I didn't even do my own, but I used libgcrypt, which is an older library for Eternal Terminal. And basically some security expert went to me and said, yeah, that library is not very secure, and so I should use libsodium instead. And then here's a bunch of reasons why, which were unintelligible to me because I should use lip sodium instead. Um, and, and here's a bunch of reasons why, which were unintelligible to me because I'm not from that field. Um, but yeah, there's just, there's a wealth of information. I mean, I, uh, um, I feel like I, it's just, it's one of those
关于它的知识。是的，我做过我自己的。其实我甚至没有自己做，我为 Eternal Terminal 使用了 libgcrypt，这是一个较旧的库。基本上有位安全专家找到我说，那个库不太安全，我应该改用 libsodium。然后他列举了一堆原因，但我听不懂，因为我不是那个领域的。但确实，那里有海量的信息。我觉得这只是其中之一，
things that's like pretty far down on my list, uh, because just only because there's so many other things that I want to learn. But, uh, um, But I could see, you know, if I got into it, I would definitely be just reading about it for days. I mean, there's just tons of amazing content. And it goes all the way back to, like, people encoding messages to help fight wars in the Roman Empire. I think that's it.
排在我的学习清单上比较靠后的位置，仅仅是因为还有太多其他我想学的东西。但我能看出，如果我深入研究，我肯定会读上好几天。那里有海量精彩的内容。它甚至可以追溯到罗马帝国时期人们为了战争而进行的加密通信。我想就是这样。
It feels like doing spy work. Like, keeping secrets just sort of seems fun. Yeah, totally. All right. spy work like keeping secrets just sort of seems fun yeah totally all right well that's uh that's the show for for this month uh cryptography i think uh is fascinating actually it came from a listener uh request so um so thank you for that definitely keep emailing us with your ideas uh Uh, you know, we keep all of them and we get to all of them eventually. And, uh, you know, it's, it's some of our best shows, especially now, you know, we've been doing this for a long time and, uh, and, uh, some of our
感觉就像在做间谍工作。保守秘密似乎很有趣。是的，完全同意。好吧，这就是本月的节目。加密技术，我认为非常迷人。其实这是一个听众的要求，所以非常感谢。一定要继续给我们发邮件分享你的想法。我们保留了所有的建议，最终都会处理。而且，这是我们最好的节目之一，尤其是现在，我们已经做了很长时间了，我们的一些
best shows have come from users saying, Hey, you know, I, I just blitzed through, you know, all five years of your show and you didn't talk about this. So the person in particular, this was, I won't say your last name, but this was Khan, who said, hey, check out, I noticed you didn't cover cryptography. Also, another gentleman by the name of Juan asked us the same thing. And because of you guys, you folks, we covered cryptography. So thank you for that. All right. Until next time.
最好的节目来自用户说：“嘿，我刚刚一口气听完了你们五年的节目，你们还没谈过这个。”特别是这位听众，我不说你的姓，但这位是 Khan，他说：“嘿，看看这个，我注意到你们还没涵盖加密技术。”还有一位叫 Juan 的先生也问了我们同样的问题。多亏了你们，我们才涵盖了加密技术。所以谢谢你们。好了，下次见。
See you later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. Binar Pilot. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布。Binar Pilot。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。